On January 14 2014 former Fullerton
Police Department officers Manuel Ramos
and Jason Ellie were acquitted of
charges in the July 2011 beating death
of Kelly Thomas 37 year-old
schizophrenic drifter
although the not guilty verdict was a
shock to supporters of the Thomas family
what may have stung even more was Sicily
statements to an Orange County newspaper
saying he would seek his job back with
the Fullerton Police Department I was
wrongfully terminated said Sisson le to
the paper how do you argue with the jury
of 12 who all agree on the same thing
residents and supporters showed up at
Fullerton City Council meeting January
21st to let the City Council members
know how they felt about Sisson Ellie's
rehiring
if this guy gets rehired it's not going
to be good for the city at all please do
not hire those other officers those
officers back really really urge the
five of you to definitely not like
Cincinnati back here he's just not
wanted here his damage has been done
Police Chief Dan Hughes was in charge of
firing Sicily in July 2012 a year after
Kelly Thomas's death I understand that
one of the officers has alleged that I
have wrongfully terminated him and that
he wants his job back I want this
community to know that I am confident in
the decision-making that I have made
regarding these former officers and I
intend to vigorously defend my position
and my decisions engage in every step of
the employment grievance process that
they have the tricky thing here is that
although Hughes has stated multiple
times that he will fight to keep Cinelli
from regaining employment with the
department Sisson le may pursue a
lawsuit to regain his job but that only
happens if an arbitration process falls
apart Sisson le will have to make his
case to an arbitrator who would make a
recommendation to the city city council
members would then vote on whether to
rehire him if he loved playing back on
Hugh says the Fullerton Police
Department has made a lot of changes and
is still changing thanks to
recommendations from an independent
review of department policies any police
officer who betrays the old that they
made to this department in betrays the
oath they make to this badge and once a
stand this badge represents I will do
everything in my lawful authority to
ensure that they never have the
privilege wearing this badge again
reforms aside the Kelly Thomas incident
is a wait many residents in the city
still carry you think of the very soul
of this city being ripped apart by a
police department I think you will hear
the screams of Kelly Thomas through
these streets especially in the downtown
forever it will never go away